[Musique]
des centaines de chats de chiens de
lapins et même des moutons des cochons
ou des chèvres sont recueillis ici dans
le refuge de la Fondation Brigitte
Bardot à Bazoches sur Guyane
[Musique]
face au nombre d'abandons importants
depuis le début de l'été le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune s'est rendu
sur place pour passer un message on est
au moment des vacances beaucoup de gens
en prennent la route c'est l'essentiel
ne le déplacement et il y a encore des
milliers d'abandon à chaque année en
France et principalement l'été c'est au
plus de 100 000 abandons chaque année
d'animaux domestiques en particulier
c'est plus de 60 000 de ses abandons
l'été ça veut dire que il y a beaucoup
de gens encore qui partent en vacances
et ça n'est malheureusement pas une
légende qui laisse un animal sur le bord
de la route ou sur une aire d'autoroute
et qui sont parfois récupérés par
beaucoup d'associations qui arrivent ici
ou évidemment ils sont pris en charge de
manière extrêmement engagée et je veux
vraiment rendre hommage à toutes celles
et ceux qui font ce travail mais on a
surtout besoin que cela n'arrive pas
saturé ce refuge a pour mission
d'accueillir les animaux de les soigner
de les accompagner jusqu'à la fin de
leur vie si ces derniers n'ont pas
réussi à être adoptés et la
problématique demeure avec l'inflation
le nombre d'adoption est en berne pour
lutter contre les abandons le
gouvernement à relancer une campagne
avec le ministère de l'Agriculture stop
abandon abandonné son animal est
également passible de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende enfin pour éviter tout effet de
mode une mesure sur la maltraitance
animale a également été adoptée
en novembre 2021 c'est d'interdire des
janvier prochain la vente des chats et
des chiens en animalerie ça à partir du
1er janvier prochain ça sera interdit il
y a aussi un travail qui doit être
encore renforcé sur les ventes par
petites annonces et plus globalement sur
les sites qui existent les réseaux
sociaux notamment
ça il y a des mesures qui sont mises en
place pour renforcer la réglementation
mais ça doit pas ça doit aller encore
plus loin et puis il y a toujours la
problématique aussi des marchés ou des
foires à chiots chatons là de la même
manière comme les animaleries il faut
arriver à une interdiction de vendre des
animaux dont on connaît pas toujours la
provenance également le ministre des
Transports a donc rappelé ce qu'implique
le permet d'avoir un animal défait de
l'engagement et un sens des
responsabilités car la Fondation
Brigitte Bardot a aussi constaté une
hausse importante des animaux maltraités
on a eu énormément de maltraitance on
sent qu'il y a un système un niveau
social qui est vraiment grave qui peut
prendre en compte parce qu'on a pas
récupéré autant de chiens maltraités
mais maltraités avec des blessures
vraiment de des coups de couteau des
choses comme ça on n'avait jamais eu ça
avant traumatisé par leur passé ici les
animaux sont bichonnés par une
quarantaine de soigneurs et peuvent
couler des jours paisibles